building on welcome to the program
wellness what does that mean to you
wellness basically is a holistic I think
idea of how we a live our lives how we
take care of each other how we honor our
day moment-to-moment
and wellness is really a part of a
mindset really on how we want to be able
to live our best life what is your best
life your best life is being mindful
caring about others eating appropriately
loving your children being there for
them enjoying life spending time in
nature understanding what it is to be
able to have an optimum experience and
being able to work with the obstacles
that come into your life with a more
optimistic view of how you can get over
the problem because life isn't easy but
it really is staying aware isn't it and
being in this present moment rather than
living in the past or ruminating all the
difficult things that you went through
so I just you know believe that it's a
day-to-day approach to being aware to
become more mindful to become happier I
was told that I'm doing an interview
with you is like a therapy session as
opposed to into my god what do you think
about I don't know that's a compliment
actually and you have lots of stress
techniques don't you that you use in
order to benefit yourself every day yes
it really is I mean first of all the one
important thing is to wake up in the
morning and go I'm alive it's great
let's go right and aside for the fact
you know you've got lots of things to do
and some of them aren't always easy but
I work out so I go into my room and I
have a trampoline and I jump on my
trampoline and I watched the news often
times I cried during the news because
it's so devastatingly horrible and then
again there's something great that comes
on I have to laugh because I'm jumping
and crying at the same time so at least
everything
being ridiculous
and then I do my yoga I ride my bicycle
with kirt we just do things ultimately
that you know get my body you know
working you know I was a dancer so it's
how I started so I can't I mean physical
activity movement is it very important
you know so they talk about sitting is
probably the worst thing you can do so
those that go to work every day breathe
get up walk around make sure you go out
for lunch you know it kind of is it's
just staying aware of what really makes
you feel good and always when you work
out you feel better we don't work out
and you know feel crazy but just move
your body no work out every single day
now you do some exercise if I can to be
honest with you here I thought I was
gonna wake up at 6:30 go down to the gym
do my walking gym I running do my
stretching do a little bit of yoga and
my my alarm didn't work good but you'll
do it at another time of day is there a
better time for you to exercise the
morning the evening what's good morning
is the best meeting yeah because if you
don't do it in the morning you say well
I'll do it in the afternoon and then
your afternoon takes you a and then you
don't do it and then at night it's not a
good time to exercise because then you
don't you don't go to sleep with all of
that energy you know so I mean it's just
morning I say morning so how do you deal
with sadness so when you're feeling
quite blue I think sadness is important
I don't shy away from being sad because
it helps you think about a what you're
sad about think about what you're think
about thinking and then when you when
you go through it the idea this is that
just like laughter is something
extraordinary
sadness is also a part of life so for us
to sort of say I'm not going to be sad
I'm not going to cry I'm gonna you know
push through this it doesn't help us
analyze or be able to feel the the
emotions that humans are supposed to
feel I think a long-term sadness is
where you have to
look at this and say okay this is
turning into depression because sadness
can turn into depression if it's not
Delvin but that means how do you know
when that's the ticket because you will
find out you don't want to wake up in
the morning you'll find out that you're
gonna you guys don't want to stay in bed
or you want to go back to bed or you
don't feel like going out or you feel
like you know that thing about stepping
out and being with friends people you
love suddenly you think I don't really
feel like being with them these are all
symptoms of aspects of being depressed
you know when we're sad we call our
girlfriends when we're sad we speak to
the people that matter and oftentimes a
psychologist but that's taking you know
a proactive approach but when you really
find you're having this intrinsic sad
feeling it doesn't go away then you
realize if we watch yourself you know
human beings have what we call mirror
neurons right we're able to actually see
others and witness others and we also
witness ourselves so we are the one
animal if you will in the kingdom that
can actually self examine we can look at
ourselves for thirty thousand feet up
and organize around what state of mind
we're in right now so it's one removed
and it's actually quite a great quality
to have as a human being why you in
London for my foundation the Goldie Hawn
foundation and that foundation has
created and I dreamed this up fifteen
years ago a program called mind up and
mind up is now we're moving now to make
sure we'll be to a hundred new schools
we have fifty sixty thousand children
now here in just in London itself doing
the program program has learned about
your brain our children need to learn
about their brains we ask them to use it
we ask them to function with it and they
know nothing about it
so neurological education I think it's
extremely valuable and that's why I put
it as the first pillar in our program
then we do mine what we do brain breaks
so it's a program it's a mindfulness
based program but it isn't just about
mindfulness it's about staying mindful
but it's also about learning all of your
emotional constructs how to quiet
down in order to lighten up the
executive function we call the
prefrontal cortex that's where we make
decisions analyze come out with some
good ideas create and it's what actually
speaks to the hippocampus what the
hippocampus can remember all of the
things that we learn when we're stressed
and and frenzied and full of anxiety
fear uncertainty whatever you want to
call it even over a happiness you
actually cannot think as well so we
teach our children that along with
positive psychology this is not Private
Benjamin talking is it no it's not I did
you in the army but I joined a different
army but it is Private Benjamin that
produced the movie that made sure it
worked that a diagnosed it so the
probability of being success of looking
at a character acutely to make sure that
she was in line with the character that
was actually written so it's a little
bit of private management yeah does it
offend you when people still sort of
think of you as a sort of ditzy image or
given that you've you've underlined and
I I know from my research that you you
know produced directed on occasion you
do all sorts of other things as well
does it bother you how people view you
see you know if I can bring any joy to
anyone it might be the greatest gift I
was given I think it's a gift I don't
even know if it comes out of me but I
feel honored I feel respectful of it and
there's nothing better nothing better
than watching people laugh and when I
see my children laughing and my school
children laughing then I'm I know why
I'm here so it's just a gift that I I
have full respect for and I would never
ever feel like bad because someone maybe
thought that it came from something else
what makes you left I laugh a lot so
it's really hard to say what makes me
laugh do you know what I mean
a funny
joke it's not about that I kind of have
this cosmic laugh which is it's a tickle
inside so I can laugh very easily at a
lot of very small things so it isn't
really about what makes me laugh
maybe the income grew to incongruity of
a reality I mean sometimes I can laugh
at people that I think are being
absolutely ridiculous
I can laugh at people who I think are
funny in spite of themselves I went to
the comedy store the other night or did
any Sunset Boulevard and I had so much
fun looking at these comedians laughing
and making me laugh and so there's all
kinds of ways of finding joy and joy is
an expression it's a a state of being
that laughter can sprout from so I say
maybe it comes from that you family
brings your loss of joy doesn't it
you're just about to be a grandmother
again yeah six times is it easier being
a grandmother than being a mother parent
oh yeah I mean you know a parent you're
you're in the thick of it you're in the
thick of it and these are your children
and your children you're not one thing
you're not gonna fail at one thing I
wasn't gonna fail that was being a
mother was being the best mother I could
be not fail I didn't want my children to
be problematic I didn't want them to
have you know any emotional problems
they will always deal with their
emotions but they'll be able to analyze
them and deal with them I wanted happy
children nurture children children that
felt that there was a what you call
closer connection and and and that was
my goal but I was also producing acting
writing stirring the pot the chicken on
the phone babies in my hand and making
sure that when I came home at night from
work that I had my mindful moment before
I walked into the house they're
everything to me
it's hard work but but I had an
intention to do it right
now that I'm a grandmother I get to help
other children but Mike but being a
grandparent it's much easier then back
at the end of the day did you want your
children to follow you into your
profession though my children were able
to choose whatever profession they
wanted
there was no pushing there was only
demonstrating um if and when they wanted
to do it they had to do it right be kind
be respectful have a work ethic and
don't expect anything and learn about
rejection because rejection is real you
go in you do your best thank you very
much and you don't get hired there's all
kinds of people that have to do become
you know a star if you want to do that
or even in the limelight for whatever
reason you'll be judged a lot of
negative things said about you people
will perceive you differently you just
have to be able to stay your own person
and be able to look at that and say
that's them and this is me and they
don't know me really so it's kind of
like a Rorschach test this is where you
look at an inkblot and you can project
whatever you want onto that but it
doesn't necessarily mean it's true so
what we wanted our children to be
healthy and balanced and that's the main
thing now do they all go into show
business
yes and Katie said to me mom I want to
do you know I don't want to go to
college right now I just want to have
one year of after school like I got that
and I will try and if it doesn't work
I'm gonna be going to NYU I said great
and of course after a year as we know
she took off Oliver went to school he
went to college for two years came back
and said mom I want to start my career
and he started in sort of the basics of
making film and Wyatt went ahead and
became a hockey player he didn't want
anything to do with show business and
now he's in it show business is very
different now isn't it to what it was
when you started and I just wanted to
talk touch briefly on the me to campaign
and then you you talked about when you
were a dancer
and you felt quite objectified didn't
you Oh
I mean you know very objectified I mean
I had a great upbringing which gave me a
very strong mother and a very strong dad
and they were both quite different but
and I was a ballet dancer so I had a
tremendous amount of would it call it
grit if you will but when I went to New
York and I went out there to try to you
know dance on you know tell not tell you
but I was on you know I want to be
onstage you know I did what I had to do
to earn money so you know I danced you
know at go-go that was the times of the
go-go dancing and I was able to make my
money that way so I could keep studying
and I danced at the World's Fair and
then I went so I was working but
objectified you know you wonder I wonder
how after what I had gone through how I
still and and and I always will learning
more about the male brain and
understanding the difficulties of how to
control their sexual urges I have a lot
of compassion I don't have compassion
for men who believe that they have these
entitlements to be able to do the things
they do to women and when they don't get
what they want to downgrade them to
abuse them verbally to make them feel
less than what they are I think that now
we're reached a point where we actually
are looking at you know equal pay an
ability to be respected there's nothing
greater than a man and a woman that can
work together because our brains are so
beautifully met different but we can
solve problems in a much refined way if
we work together it doesn't always work
that does it like the First Wives Club
illustrates beautifully
[Laughter]
I washed shorts I iron into my starch
them I've had two successful marriages
you've been married before haven't you
but then you decided not to marry Kurt
no I don't want to marry no neither does
he
why not because it was great you know we
were I was married twice it didn't work
marriage didn't mean suddenly everything
was gonna work and the last thing you
want to do is stay with an income an
institution that you know basically says
here's the rules here's the way it is
and so on and so forth um I'm not that
kind of person it didn't work that's
fine it was just problem solving really
and Kurt felt the same way and so we
decided we didn't want to get married
right so then I guess about ten years
into our marriage we said okay guys now
and you think we should get married and
they all said no no they loved it the
way it was they felt good they felt
secure and I think it's important now do
our children want to get married yes so
it's not about not getting married
it's about waking up every morning and
saying am I in love is this the right
place for me to be are we sharing the
right things do we have a family to love
and protect together do we have basic
needs and basic drives and basic
objectives those are the things that we
look at to find out what are the seeds
of happiness that we're planting do you
have any mindful techniques that you
could maybe teach me yeah I mean first
of all you know a mindful technique
starts with quieting the mind and when
you learn to quiet your mind and you
learn to settle down all of those
thoughts and all of that talk and all of
that self-talk then you'll be able to
really start watching your mind instead
of just being inside of it where you
can't find your way into a peaceful
situation all by yourself so I would say
that the first thing to do is to take
time throughout your day whether it's in
the morning I think morning afternoon
evening is great a lot of people believe
that 12 you know of 20 minutes in the
morning is good I think it's great a lot
of us don't have time so I would quiet
my mind I would follow my breath and
realize that breath does change the
brain so when you're breathing and you
breathe in and you breathe out you begin
to relax your entire body and your brain
when your brain is now watching all the
thoughts that are going through your
brain let them drift away don't attach
yourself to any thoughts your brain
thinks no matter what so we're called
taming the brain and creating more
mental Fitness that's how we're able to
let go the thought and go back to breath
just to follow that and when you begin
you start strengthening these positions
in your body and your mind that actually
reduces stress and is able to actually
watch yourself so it develops Fitness
metacognition and also self-regulation
so therefore when your children are
bothering you when your husband might be
upsetting you for some reason or just
being outside and seeing all how crazy
people are out there driving their cars
and you know losing you know road rage
or whatever you want to call what at
work whatever it is take a breath sit
down and realize that it's it's only a
job it's only a car it is your children
it is what matters and you will then
realize to do what's right
reactivity is a very very dangerous
thing to have when you're working and
especially for your children so I that
would be the first thing I would say to
become more mindful it really is like a
therapy session rather than an interview
goli hold thank you very much you bet
thank you thank you
you